hello everyone and welcome to the third
game between magnus carlson and daniel
dubo
from the opera you were rapid knockouts
i thought i'd only do like uh
one or two maybe videos today but these
guys are just going all out and
we have to see uh such brilliancies so
without further ado
let's check it out double needs a win to
get back into the match so can he do it
again
now he has the white pieces and he opens
with d4
uh we have knight to f6 by magnus c4 e6
knight to f3 and now
b6 bags magnus goes for the queens
indian defense
uh we have g3 and now bishop to b7 the
early fiance of the light square bishop
uh duboff does the same and the bishop
to be for czech the so-called capoblanca
variation of the queen's indian uh we
have bishop to d2
and now c5 striking in the center we
have bishop captures uh
c captures and now both players castle
so castles castles
and knight b to d2 so black has the the
double b pawn but he's gonna play a5 at
some point uh
and uh you know uh strengthen them and
then he will use his semi-open file
uh for the rook so here the immediate a5
and
rook the e1 double is preparing to push
in the center with e4
we have d6 and now e4 and now magnus
goes for
knight f to d7 yeah if you try and
develop this knight too early then
you're gonna run into d5 or something
like that
so here at knight after uh d7 preparing
to bring the queen
into the game and here just queen to e2
dubo connects uh the rooks uh brings the
queen into the game
and now there are some games where
knight to c6 and knight the a6 were
played
but here we have e5 and it is as of move
12 that we have a
completely new game so let's see how do
both deals
with this uh novelty he goes rook 8 to
d1
finishes development and now knight to
c6 magnus still needs to bring the
both of the rooks into the game and now
knight to f1
makes sense as the f5 square is free for
for the knight and if
magnus wants to prevent the knight
coming to f5 he's gonna have to weaken
his king side with g6
so here queen to f6 and now knight to e3
there was uh
also the possibility of just trading
here captures captures in knight h4
then trying to bring the knight here as
now the d file would open up
uh but uh uh duboff prefers to keep it
uh
still intact with knights to e3
and magnus trades once night capture
sunday for knight
captures on d4 and e cactus on d4 and
now
uh dubo doesn't go for knight to f5
which seems like a reasonably
uh reasonable idea as both of these uh
pawns are under attack also e5
could happen at some point the bishop on
b7 is undefended
uh but the dubois goes for the instant
e5 and now
uh what's the idea here his knight is
still attacked and he's now attacking
the bishop here and the carlson's queen
so carlson needs to capture this he
plays bishop uh queen captures on e5
and now uh bishop captures on b7 uh we
rook the a7 you have to play this
otherwise uh if captures just bishop
captures rook so rook to a7 temporarily
uh magnus is down a piece but he will
recapture one of these so
queen to g4 by duboff now saying okay if
you capture my piece then bad things
will happen
and it is in fact true if you capture
for the bishop for example
knight d5 and it's game over the queen
has nowhere to go you have to play
something like knight f6 attack white's
queen
but after queen f3 uh that's it the
queen still has to move and
once you capture this knight this comes
with check and you're gonna pick up the
rook here
so in short let's say queen g5 just
captures captures and now queen captures
on b7
that white is up for a whole rook so
after queen to g4
knight f6 the only good move for magnus
and now queen
captures on d4 so grabbing a pawn now
magnus needs to spend the move to
recapture the piece otherwise dubo will
just be up material
so rook captures on b7 and now queen
captures on d6
grabbing yet another pawn and now the uh
material is equal on the board and
magnus has to decide whether he wants to
go for this
sort of equalish endgame do with pieces
are a bit more active
or he wants to try and grab the b2 pawn
now is the b 2.3 for grabs
uh let's let's grab it and check it out
and magnus did play
queen captures on b2 but now do both
plays
rook to d2 and now there aren't all that
many squares for this black queen to go
to there's the a3 square and there's the
c3 square
a3 square is the only possible square
for the black queen but magnus
played uh queen to c3 and now there's a
problem
feel free to pause the video and win
this game for duba while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
move with the knight back
also for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show yeah it's knight to d1
attacking the queen and the queen has
nowhere to go uh
problem is uh the queen cannot uh the
queen cannot move uh from this square if
you play something like queen to a3
uh now the rook's file opened up and of
course uh
what comes next is just amazing queen
captures on f8 with
check king captures and rook to d8 and
the only move is knight to e8 you have
to block check and now either rook and
capture and the deliver checkmate
so this is what's being threatened after
knight to d1 so magnus of course said
okay i can't do this i'm going to try
rook to e8
uh even though there's very little uh i
can do here and now dubo has
several ways he can win this he can just
play queen to b8 uh it's a beautiful
move where magnus would have to
have to resign there's no move for black
to play here but the dubo made it simple
and he simply played
rook captures with check knight captures
and now knight characters on c3
and it was in this position unmoved 25
uh that magnus carlsen resigned the game
and
dubo is back in the match so here you
resign because
whatever you do you're gonna end up down
a piece you of course have to recapture
the queen
and then comes rook captures knight and
you cannot capture on c3 because of rook
d8
checkmate and once you stop checkmate
you save the knight
white is up a piece of course completely
winning so insane game by double insane
all the games by dubois so just amazing
stuff to bounce back after losing to
carlson
uh so badly yesterday now it seems to do
with him up to the floor
mop the floor with magnus uh so i think
they're going straight into the tie
breaks we'll see what happens there and
who will
who will take this uh match uh you know
and go into the semi-finals who will be
very interesting
so that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it uh congratulations once again to
everyone who found uh who found the
knight to d1 wound up not an easy move
to find uh i would like to thank enrique
salami
tito renaldo justin pollard and david
kimber for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the uh you're
rapid checking up on your one of the
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day